Ici, Abe Lucas va rejoindre la
faculté, c'est vraiment quelque chose que j'aime un peu
le look burnout oh mon dieu j'ai besoin de
lire Richard, c'est tellement bon de t'avoir
ici, elle a besoin que nous ayons déjà rencontré le gars
et je suis déjà jaloux  pour emménager dans le mien
on a parlé à maman c'est dans le monde tout
le temps je pense qu'il aime
assez se garder j'étais effet comme restaurer
et tu sais combien il aimait tellement il y a
une différence entre un
monde théorique de conneries de philosophie
et la vraie vie  il jouait récemment,
il est juste fascinant parce qu'il est
brillant mais il souffre de blocages
ouais, c'est vrai, je ne peux pas respirer, tu as besoin d'une
muse,
je suis tellement intéressant et différent,
qu'est-ce que tu fais Eve, c'est
une leçon existentielle meilleure que dans  les
crises d'angoisse des manuels j'espère juste que
tu ne commences pas à trop t'occuper de lui
tu peux voir pourquoi tu pourrais être jaloux
Tom c'est idiot la vérité c'est que j'ai été
attiré par un malgré ou était-ce parce qu'il
était une âme perdue c'est une mauvaise idée n'est-ce pas
qu'est-ce qui se passe, c'est à ce moment-là
que ma vie s'est complètement perdue,
je ne peux pas, je ne peux plus continuer à te voir,
je m'excuse pour tous les ennuis que j'ai
causés,
d'accord, alors de quoi parlons-nous ici,
choix moral
l'esthétique le hasard de la vie
tu